I want my hair back anyway this video is
dedicated to help you bros I know a lot
of you bros are struggling you want to
be noticed by senpai and I consider
myself a level 5 anime expert a bleach
Naruto I've seen like half the seasons
so I put together a 5 step tutorial on
how to be noticed by senpai
you
number item number one the hair this is
obviously not going to do it let's
change it
yes so to be noticed by some pie you
need an emu hair I can't [ __ ] see
anything this is the hair from miku-chan
but literally any hair color that looks
like it's candy will do look if I fix oh
I could be a I could be an animal model
step number two the outfit let's change
it I'll just change I guess
Horace the horrors I have seen families
let me show you how I work it
now if you feel extra snazzy you might
want to accessorize with some cute ears
some PI loves cute ears this is worst
than that one time I smeared a dick all
over my face
Sugoi ash [ __ ] look for somebody to
notice you you need to be you need to
know all the animal so you might want to
wear some animal accessories this one is
clearly from Naruto and it might show
that you are into kinky [ __ ] you know
what screw that if you want to be into
kinky [ __ ] you can just wear one of
these how do they work I don't know I
don't understand
did this looks good okay all right so
that's a good start but we have more
would know it's a time already
sponsor eagle sponsor eagle what have
you blessed us with this month here I
bring you a new trait obviously I work
for new sponsor people thank you another
lootcrate like every month how could I
not have guessed this every month we
unbox this lootcrate
last month was heroes so this month is
going to be Billings if you order before
the 19th each month you will get the
same loot crate and if you go to Luke
Raycom slash boots and enter the code
Parris you get 10% off whoa all right
first item is the Joker and it's a
painted wooden finger ah so cute
hahahaha thank you falling up that's
adorable
almost as cute as I am next one is
Captain America a badge pin I will put
this on my backpack so people know that
I'm into Captain America
what is this this looks weird what is
this oh it's awesome
but yes this has to be one of my
favorite items it's it's a kitchen like
cover with los Pollos at - from Breaking
Bad that's [ __ ] awesome
that's brilliant I love this that's so
[ __ ] cool woo the last box is huge
whoa what oh my god whoa it's a cup
venom yeah let's [ __ ] bad-ass that's
a bad edge cup man I don't know what to
tell you
so yeah it's if you enjoy opening stuff
every month just getting it everyone
loves getting a package right so if you
enjoy that go to Luke Raycom slash pay
attention to code parents get 10% off
everyone is happy
now let's become an emo as [ __ ] if you
want to be noticed by some pie you need
to be prepared all the time even when
you are asleep so we had these animal
sleep covers so that you can spy for
senpai even when you're asleep now I
can't really see or do anything right
now but I'm guessing I was pretty cool
I'm winking
thumbnail and then I can't really see
anything but this is a mouse cover very
good for your wrist if you have a gamer
mark like I do then these butt cheeks or
boobs will do you justice we have what's
his name again Miku from parasite pretty
cool and of course my favorite anime
Naruto I love this anime I really
recommend it
then I bought this box of like my my
favorite step anime character miku let's
get the plastic off so yeah this is my
favorite animal can't really see
I'm just gonna go so yeah thank you both
so much for watching and thanks for
checking out a loot crate it supports
the show I really appreciate it
things we're leaving like I really
appreciate it and as always thinking
about so much for watching my videos and
showing your support there's a brofist
to show my appreciation say awesome
press